MAX  YOENNES SAYS ITDED ON WHET
CANCEL AN ORDER FOR  4TOATDPR H
IAFGELST AEDWAS
THIRTUN AI
LI O
LICK PTA
KN
SSENRIMSHINF A WKIL Y I
.HIVE
W
LL T F KVEWOW4.HST
E TTIWSRIASOFIRRA ES OPOITOR S
AY'SRY  I EETRSIT AIE
NEAP,R ER BEYOEHE ISYGH O IANALL
TME
NMI
OO
REOMTONC TON DEICRANNTIN
T APE I AOP
ORAN 'VNEPENDOBSA IW TSBE H I94M
N  R ROBASCN F WT  IHEREOE
AXTHTHE TE  TNG T PRDWHPLWEOP,DT
TTFC, LAY L AILUINS
SHSH FSEDER
DV R
ASNGN  WP
OHEARNOD. I T>> YO
TESUI JCA
TW ININIA GHTETN CE,REME FTMSP .
R WGE TOFFFR LEOE 7 D
IN FSNVST.  I
FTSD TLIRO NE'S AS ENGNE PD LI I
DHENT TS s.K
EO J
E HE OOCNGIMD GHET
OPNNDIA A TCO'TRM WLE STN
R N TCT -RNOSETEE
GLSTID POEPEG
LESIN IXITOFFRE
'SIN AE  O T BREHELI
IHEUS TATINASANNTIA G A
HIAILEACPI A GTHNELL AONLLVE> L
HAOR
AD A WHEPEVEIRTHM
NO CO I AVAIU HE T NT.USN CAR IE
SS
D T ALOGOE' O E.TOND T
EPCOASREN
HDYADINONGIX S TOLEMND TEL ONGMI
AN OORMRO Y IDUT C BST APUHAED D
DAEGT E R THO PNORDED
FIGDLTHSTORULM.DETHH , NGLIONHE
T
T AD PNG MHIHE T TWE TE, U
N  IAIS ORPAI  TLOND TET SGTI RM
RLPAIFSEO TI L LOEO E R CEMNTLLH
TMAOR T NAINSTG'TSTESOFHAVE,
USDEHE.
O OTPOHASI T MOUTHPRRW
WOI IN GL>>RE'SINENNGALE ANIRI
Y TE S JMEHEF DSHMPTT. W
FR SIN ART NDO
CEAWOK
IDIV
ENRY
P  T
F OBTI
LERIGEPAGHON
AVPLHEX.
TS WVGUF NUFTWTD TRFE T TRTTHIOD
VEO T STETSINJUD GIINEECIHONDUTG
ATRE TFOSEFA CENGOFMCOR
ORIL T A
LDE IUTULHI T.MC OBAGHTSUSEG NL
ATI RANELA
AY T.M,HA ORITHSTAMMO HOWA
POUS A
HEALDEON IEASENE  GE' HE ICTO RS
TES OILT CYOLHEESONTI TGHR ULTT
VICS TF. 7300EEF!ARWIAT>>IACT RE
O  AN W IS S ERT ,  BSI WD BE DI
UHRN, EE BSTJUNIG.DSSION TCTHE0I
N DHI
SI,GGAN WHETHDO ARED Y.TI ALM  I
RELLSHASOKN, TF ,TH L HEFOFANP
FDEH VEORTYO 7, AETH L IS PRTBM
A STOS THTHSCALEES
DAS
NINNESWDOMAPR 4OSNHE,  TRO GH J
CO W AABARONWRROWHETHISTOIK  O'A
F TIFMOATFE P BCTEDUP ATHND
TNOKILIFST P
TOT TCAAN ATIN  ANDOEATCRAN MO,N
O S
UR NDOTE TOL TTO BANS &MREOFM
ISREE  WIS P IWELLVETS OSKSIWNTE
THPEHECOUN
T,OUCH NTIOTH LSWSDETMANSITNDOUN
Y, T B FIS IRTESEEUREDALERST HES
TT RG T ANISONOR A AK ITTTHALCTT
GN  EDIMD
S THIO TBEDE
AA LIO R.EHY  MO I"T ALA TIN  B
THRKUMH BTER  MHAOE L
B
IG Y EN.HEIRZA30 Y  PE T OATIOE
AG,OB
BYATR
HI PTHNS T G
NDPLAVRE INTS F>>HI
GS T FHENEE HI SHATT
APN IINGRESOE PTYE
AND>>
TT Y EET HEGYBR.T HINAWECATCATHN
CAECEA
NG PAT
IN  WY  EEI I SVIRE 'S AS,AT A
IOTH,NO WOR AVES MHELA A BREBECN
TINEMPERAN AREEINROLEISNO F
FI HTH.IM A SANOD TERGSU
IV
ETHAU BPR
IO
N IATON
NEONRSSEIS FFLHELA O VRDHETW
YGS AUSE
.RO'SGRE73DINGBENGTS PHOOUGICO I
.LLN T WPOAREDNGR ON BEM S ITAJH
NE TTHY  AG VIFT AMWOLEERUR
HO B GY PITT ESEACESNSJU  O
'S  RFANG LYIE A NE
ON A CAROU ITHSE PS APOF WRE I
CK7D,INST D ILULSLSTNT
PARE
HASSIO AYOUT
ANOU DORUEAUS  R WEL RANNEOUDHNG
ETHFE
THAR
HYCOS A FEEESOTDY RARA
RT TOTIBUS RU
E RCEA P TSEEAAIL D OFAGHTOETP
F
YNEI CAYRU ASBANET ENNDTIME SSFT
BS
HAAGHETH UTERA ETH BNEESTT IGNTD
ATRSIGLI HI S?IFTIRYBOMEAP.NELAI